hey what is up guys mkbhd here and every
single gopro from the first one all the
way through to 2015 has been a rectangle
until now so this is the newest gopro
this is the gopro hero4 session i really
want to like it but here's what it's all
about so first off yes it's a cube it
resembles that 99
polaroid cube camera except a lot less
colorful it's just all black all around
so this session is a one and a half inch
cube all the way around and has a big
lens on the front and just two buttons
so it's a really simple camera to use
kind of seems like a beginner gopro at
first although it really isn't but it
just has one big record button up top
and a little lcd display and then the
sides are pretty clean and behind the
door on the left side is a micro sd card
slot and a micro usb port for charging
and data which is kind of nice that you
can use your phone charger unlike with
other gopros that use mini usb
and there's only one other button on the
session on the back and that's the info
slash wi-fi button so it lets you view
the settings you're recording in or set
up a wi-fi connection to your phone and
that's it oh it has two microphones
one on the front top corner and then one
on the back near the bottom button but
then yeah that's it no other buttons no
removable battery it's packed and all of
this by itself out of the box is fully
functional and waterproof and that is
the main selling point the fact that the
fully waterproof gopro hero4 session is
50 smaller and 35 percent lighter than a
fully waterproof gopro hero4 silver or
black so alright it's a little bit
smaller and lighter but the other gopros
i already thought were already pretty
small and light anyway so what are the
other differences between the session
and the others well first of all since
it's a square that means you can orient
it any way you want in its mount so if
you want to side mount it on something
instead of top mounting it doesn't
require buying new accessories you can
just take it out and rotate it in its
mount put it back in sideways and boom
you're good to go so that's actually
really convenient but then on the other
side of the spectrum not having any real
display
is kind of inconvenient the small lcd on
the top just displays your settings as
you're recording but in order to change
any of your recording settings you kind
of need to have your phone with you
paired with the gopro app and that's
where you can change you know your video
resolution or time lapse speed or
anything else like that the gopro app is
really where all that stuff is found it
also works as a viewfinder with a pretty
minimal delay so that works really well
but when you're going out for like an
adventure with a gopro like this you
probably don't also have your not
waterproof smartphone with you so you'll
want to pick your settings ahead of time
so you can leave your phone somewhere
safe so to record a video with the gopro
session all you do is pick it up and
press the red button on top wait a few
seconds
and then it turns on
and just starts rolling
so press it again and it stops recording
and then turns off so there's no standby
mode it's just either on and recording
or off and it does this actually to save
battery so i actually found it it worked
really well the smaller battery in here
lasted just as long as the hero4 silver
but then again that four second delay
when trying to record the action when it
was off might also feel inconvenient if
you're in the middle of something
you don't have that delay on other
gopros where you can have it on but not
recording you can also hold down the red
button for three seconds to start a time
lapse with whatever interval you chose
in the app with up to eight megapixel
photos and the quality
ah the quality is okay but it's
definitely not as good as even the other
gopros or some of the other action
cameras out there like sony's or
panasonic's it looks about as soft and
muddy as you'd expect from any tiny
handheld camera that maxes out at a
widescreen 1080p not that 1080p is a bad
thing it's plenty for most people but it
just doesn't look like a good 1080p
colors are a little bit dull dynamic
range is definitely limited and it still
has that super wide angle look people
love but it's not exactly team crispy
and one might think that it would make
maybe a really good vlogging camera
since it has the improved microphones
for the underwater helping and it's a
really super small form factor
then again the gopro hero4 silver is the
same exact price and has much better
video quality and has switchable
batteries if you want to vlog for more
than two hours of this battery lasts so
again it's kind of one-upped by his
brother so that's why it's so hard to
recommend this little guy it's not like
it's a bad product or anything it's
built really well it's dense it's
waterproof this stuff works perfectly
but at 400 bucks it's not exactly cheap
and at that price i start to also look
for good video quality on top of just
being well built here's a shot i took
with the gopro hero4 silver not even the
black in 4k but the silver which is the
same price as the session and then the
same shot with the session it looks
totally different you can see in the
side by side that you're clearly getting
you know sacrifice and some detail with
the session some people will care about
this detail more than others but it's
not just detail the color it's the
exposure it's the dynamic range and
neither of these images is edited
honestly looking through the session
footage made me appreciate the gopro
hero 4 black that much more turns out
that thing is a seriously impressive
camera with a killer image for 500 bucks
and we already knew that but the
comparison makes it way more clear and
then the hero4 silver is a great buy for
the same price as a session 400 bucks so
at the end of the day it got me thinking
who are these gopros for who is this
session for
i originally thought it was sort of like
a beginner gopro you know it's smaller
lightweight waterproofed out the box
you're just good to go with this and
then if you want to step up your game
later you pick up a regular gopro but at
a 400 price tag for this one
no
so basically this is just better for
water sports things like water skiing or
like swimming where it's attached to you
underwater or
i guess when it really needs to be light
and weight like like when you're maybe
attaching it to a pet or something or
they'll notice the weight of a larger
gopro and even for that the regular
gopros are still pretty good and for
everything else i'd still recommend the
regular gopros or even other action
cameras so there you go that's basically
it thanks for watching this is the gopro
hero4 session feel free to leave a
comment or hit that like button if you
enjoyed talk to you guys in the next one
peace
you